will now talk about the breakpoint
graphs the workhorse of genome
rearrangement studies let's take a look
at two genomes a read genome P and blue
genome Q and now let's arrange the black
edges of Q in the same order they
arranged in genome P so they will be
arranged as plus a minus B minus C plus
D and how the genome Q will look like in
the case of this new arrangement of it's
black edges we do not change an 'm q if
you just show it differently so after we
look at genome a so after a view should
go to C that's what we do after C we
should go to be after B we should go to
minus D and after minus DV should go to
a so that's a new representation of Q
where black edges are arranged exactly
in the same way as they arranged in P as
as soon as we've done it we can
superimpose genome P view genome Q
because black edges are arranged
identically and we'll get something that
is called the breakpoint
it's absolutely unclear yet what is the
value of this breakpoint graph so let's
learn a few things about the breakpoint
graph so the first question red and
black edges in breakpoint graph what do
they correspond to of course
they correspond to genome P because
breakpoint graph is simply obtained by
superimposing of P and Q what about blue
and black edges what do they correspond
of course they correspond to genome Q
and now they ask strange question what
about red and blue edges of what would
they correspond and here what happened
when we limit our attention to red and
blue edges and they do not like like
corresponding to anything the thing that
you may notice however is that
and blue edges for alternating red blue
cycles in the breakpoint graph
why because you may notice that at every
node there is a single red edge and a
single blue edge meeting answer for the
resulting graph must consist of
alternating red blue cycle red after
every red blazer is a blue edge and
after every blue edge razor edge will
pay attention to one important parameter
of the breakpoint graph which is the
cycle number the cycle number is simply
number of red blue alternating cycles in
the breakpoint graph why do we care
about the cycle number but before the I
explain this let's try an example let's
construct the breakpoint graph for this
two genomes P and Q P consists of a
single chromosome and Q consists of two
frames the first thing we do we arrange
black edges of Q in the same order they
are present in genome P so it will be
this arrangement of black edges in Q and
then we will have to represent genome Q
on this order how do we do this well we
start from a after a V knows that we
should go to minus C afterwards we go to
minus F afterwards we go to minus C and
finally we return black back to plus a
and they continue the same way to show a
small Rama so movies just to synteny
block right here as soon as we
represented genome Q in this way we can
superimpose P and Q and we get the
breakpoint graph and after we remove
black edges from the breakpoint graph we
see that the cycle number of P and Q is
equal to 3 because there are three
cycles in this graph now given genome P
I want to ask you what is the genome Q
that maximizes the cycle number well the
cycle number will be much
demise if every cycle will be small and
the shorter cycle consists of just two
edges one red and one blue edge which
means this is a breakpoint graph with
the maximum number of alternating cycles
and of course this breakpoint graph
correspond to the case when genome Q and
genome P are identical and the number of
cycles in this graph is of course simply
the number of blocks in genome P so in
this case the number is 4 so important
thing to realize that genome
rearrangements affect red-blue cycle
every two breaks makes its mark on the
breakpoint graph and we know that
starting from the breakpoint graph
between genome P and Q doesn't matter
what series of rearrangements nature
takes the end will be the breakpoint
graph of two identical genomes and we
know how it looks like it looks like the
identity breakpoint graph who this the
maximum number of cycles and we will
explore this fact despite the fact that
series of to break transforming P into Q
is unknown we know that number of cycles
between P and Q in this case two must
change into maximum number cycles
between P and Q which in this case is
four and this is just an example of one
possible scenario for the arrangement of
genome P into genome Q but doesn't
matter what the scenario is it always
will be the change from cycle PQ to
maximum number of cycles in the graph
and armed with this observation they are
ready to prove the to break theorems
that will prove very important for our
analysis of the random breakage model